hello everybody my name is markiplier
and no the title is not a lie I did get
pepper sprayed I got pepper sprayed real
bad right in the face it wasn't an
accident it was in a controlled
environment we did this over honest
honest if you want to see the full video
there's a link in the description
that'll take you to the full video that
details from start to finish but I had
to make a video just talking about the
experience as you've judged by the
thumbnail which you can see here this is
real that is what it looked like the
only thing I did to that picture is I
sharpened it and I boosted the
saturation just a little bit but that's
how nasty this stuff was and how direct
a hit I got in my face and I want to
talk about just the sheer amount of pain
like the legitimate non-stop burning
pain of getting pepper sprayed if you
know me you know I've been through some
painful things in my life I've eaten a
lot of hot peppers I've had some
surgeries here and there I've broken a
bone in my life I've cracked my skull
open I've done a lot of things that were
very painful including getting my hands
burned to the second degree I've been
through burns and I can tell you without
a shadow of a doubt this stuff hurt
worse than that and that hurt real bad
like really really bad but this stuff
was designed to make you feel in agony
the one thing about the pepper spray is
and I've got a video here that I want to
show you guys let's actually take a look
you can see the full video over on unas
honest links in the description
like Ethan got a good shot and I got
just this direct blast in my eyes I'm
not saying I got it worse than him we
got the same amount it's just starting
to burn real bad that's so much worse
it's burning like as if there's
something hot oil on my eyes ah God it's
kicking up in intensity it's starting to
creep into my eyes
don't touch your face it's definitely in
my eyes now yep I'm sorry for spitting
up over your the burn is still going up
God [__] that burns so [__] bad
you're fine you're fine man you got this
I feel be able to open my eyes again
it's fine okay so with this stuff like
like I said you can watch the full video
over there this was no joke
I also want to make this video to say
like we were in a controlled environment
with trained professionals on hand to
help when we needed help we did it and
we were going three minutes before we
started washing it out just to really
get the full experience of it and part
of the reason why I did this is because
I wanted to know how bad it really was
I wanted to know like how it matched up
to the other like experiences of pain in
my life and one of the worst things
about it is not so much the burning it's
the fact that you can't breathe the
reason he was saying in through the nose
and out through the mouth is because if
you try to suck in air through your
mouth your breath will catch in your
throat and you'll end up swallowing air
that's what happened to me and I wasn't
able to get a breath it didn't feel good
because the panic hits and you want to
hyperventilate but you have to control
your breathing you have to control the
panic because otherwise you'll just
start to like really scramble for breath
when you're already scrambling because
of the pain
and and at first because I'd never
experienced it before that's that's what
happened I just had this overwhelming
sense of panic I was just like oh [__]
but because I've been through pain
before him because I've been through hot
peppers I know it'll pass
but this thing just kept climbing this
video right now were two minutes and 51
seconds into the experience of the
pepper spray and it was only going up
from there so almost immediately after
this yes so immediately after that we
started getting like this stuff washed
out and the reason we use water first we
had milk as well but it's just like a
quantity thing it's just a quantity
thing you need like to wash it out as
much as possible the reason this stuff
was is used because it's a special like
pepper spray that they use in prisons
and stuff like that because it sticks to
the individual that it was sprayed on
it's not a spray that goes everywhere
it's sticks and because of that this
stick just stays and stays and stays and
it's super hard to get off and you don't
want to wash with soap because that'll
spread it everywhere it'll lift it off a
little bit and then it'll just spread it
cuz it won't just like fall off your
skin so you just got a wash wash wash so
Ethan and I we cycled out but the pain
kept going up it took 40 minutes before
the pain started going back down that's
how long this experience lasted it was
rough the whole way through and I want
to make a disclaimer I don't think any
of you are like going out to go try this
but be aware do not try this do not try
this we were in a professional setting
with people that are security experts
and people ready to give medical
mention as needed in the video you'll
probably see they were checking our
heart rate we had our watches going
check in our heart rate making sure we
were good so do not try this okay good
just wanted to clear that up but all in
all I am glad that I tried it and I'm
super proud of Ethan for trying it with
me
he was obviously nervous you know
there's this running joke that I love
pain I do not love pain but I like
seeing what I can handle I like knowing
that I can conquer something I know that
I can beat a pain because I have been
through pain in my life I have been
through pain before and I have come out
stronger for it I'm not saying that
you'll come out stronger for this
because the day after this experience it
was such a long stint of just feeling
this tension from the adrenaline pumping
through my veins and just the sheer like
trying to hold it together that my neck
just ached beyond ache the whole next
day I was exhausted as if I had just run
a marathon because that's probably the
equivalent of what my body went through
just to handle this pain for the amount
of duration and the amount of time that
I did it it was nuts and I felt it the
next day and I've been training I've
been getting in shape so it's not like
even a physical exhaustion it's like a
central nervous system exhaustion the
adrenaline just like spikes through your
heart rate goes up and just the panic in
your mind and the pain just going
through your body it tires you out it
really does so anyway I wanted to make
this video just as a supplemental to
this other experience if you want to see
the full video of this and I recommend
you do and please go check it out leave
a like for the sake of our pain there
and like una songs man moon as honest
there was this was nuts
beyond nuts and frankly one of the most
painful experiences I've ever been
through easily one of the most painful
not the most painful but one
of the most painful so if you want to
know what getting pepper sprayed is like
go check out the video so thank you
everybody so much for watching I'm fine
now I don't plan to get febris braids
ever again for the rest of my life but
now I can say with pride that I know
what it's like I know the pain I get it
and I understand that and that can that
that's something that I can hold in my
heart and go forward with confidence and
I can speak with confidence about it and
I can confidently say it sucks so go
check out the video links in the
description thanks everyone and as
always I'll see you in the video down
there bye bye